on passe tout de suite à notre second
débat vous le savez je vous le disais
tout à l'heure volontairement décalée de
l'actualité du jour c'est le plus
souvent un débat de société qui
d'ailleurs peut permettre aussi
d'éclairer les enjeux campagne
présidentielle et je rappelle que vous
pouvez réagir pendant cette émission
avec le mode yeahs le hashtag sens
public se soit on analyse un combat sans
fin celui de l'égalité femmes hommes et
on commence par un bilan de la parité en
politique avec aurélien romano la parité
en politique a commencé à devenir
effective il ya un peu plus de vingt ans
et la loi du 6 juin 2000 qui instaure la
parité obligatoire pour les listes de
candidats aux élections municipales
régionales ou départementales ainsi que
l'alternance femmes hommes pour les
candidats d'une liste cette joie un
sport aussi des pénalités pour les
partis ne respectant pas cette parité
nouvelle étape en 2007 afin de féminiser
les exécutifs locaux dans les communes
de plus de 3500 habitants la loi
instaure la parité pour l'élection des
adjoints dernière grande étape 2013 la
loi instaure le binôme pour les
élections départementales et le seuil
est à baisser aux communes de 1000
habitants le chantier de la parité est
aussi celui de l'incitation pour les
femmes à s'engager s'engager c'est
prendre du temps sur le temps personnel
le temps de la famille et donc il faut
avoir des structures des réunions des
organisations qui permettent une bonne
articulation du temps personnel et du
temps professionnel ou d'engagement
politique aujourd'hui près de la moitié
des conseillers départementaux et
régionaux sont des femmes et elles
représentent aussi 42 % des conseillers
municipaux mais dès qu'il s'agit d'un
carnation dans la présidence d'exécutif
là par les femmes diminue fortement
trois femmes présidentes sur treize
régions métropolitaines seulement un
président de département sur cinq est
une femme même proportion chez les mères
19 8% et le taux tombe à 11 % dans les
intercommunalités on va devoir légiférer
à nouveau puisque les conseils
départementaux finalement désormais ne
sont pas arrêtés avec les binômes eh
bien on a avancé pour les conseils
départementaux
on n'a pas perdu en efficacité à partir
du moment où il y avait des femmes donc
oui il faut je crois passé par des
quotas des règles plus contraignantes
pour voir plus de femmes arrivé en
politique les pistes à l'étude sont la
parité dans l'exécutif des affaires
comme unité et la parité pour les
communes de moins de 1000 habitants qui
représente près de trois quarts des
communes certaines associations
proposent aussi une mesure indirecte la
limitation des mandats dans le temps
afin de renouveler les maires plus
souvent pour le moment le gouvernement
n'a pas prévu de légiférer à nouveau sur
la parité
et pour en débattre j'accueille
dominique estrosi sassone bonsoir en
sorte sénatrice l ère des
alpes-maritimes céline pic bonsoir porte
parole du mouvement osez le féminisme
est risqué rouge bonsoir sénateur ps des
landes matthieu croissandeau était à mes
côtés dominique estrosi sassone sur
votre fiche d'identité sur le site du
sénat vous est présentée comme sénateur
sony vous n'aimez pas le terme sénatrice
en tout cas les deux peuvent se dire oui
mais je préfère qu'on dise sénateurs
parce que c'est la référence à la
fonction de sénateur voilà tout
simplement je trouve qu'elle est titres
qui sont plus ou moins heureux en termes
de féminisation c'est intéressant ça
ouvre bien le débat parce que c'est une
pique j'imagine que pour vous c'est un
enjeu ça va si la féminisation des
métiers ou des fonctions et 6-1 6-1 en
jeu parce qu'il ya un enjeu de
représentation c'est à dire que le
pouvoir a tendance à être perçu comme
quelque chose de masculin certains
candidats d'ailleurs à la présidentielle
revendique le fait que le pouvoir est
intrinsèquement masculin et de féminiser
les titres puisque on voit bien que ce
qui a été
les titres qui ne sont pas au féminin ce
sont les types de pouvoirs coiffeuse ça
existe par contre effectivement c'est
difficile de faire changer les choses et
moi on me dit bien sûr pour une
féminisation total des titres pour dire
que les femmes peuvent aussi un
vestiaire les postes de pouvoir alors on
va démarrer sur cette idée de la parité
en politique alors on a quand même
progressé en france pense que tout le
monde pourra faire ce ce constat grâce
aux différentes lois mais quand même on
en parlait hier au congrès des maires de
france
ce chiffre seuls 20% des maires sont des
femmes écoutez ce qu'on disait stéphane
le foll le maire du mans il faut
sûrement progresser je vous rappelle que
sur les grandes agglos c'est pas le cas
dans les communes de moins de 3500
habitants les lys sont paritaires
totalement paritaire mois que ce soit à
la ville ou à la métropole on est sur
des binômes avec une première adjointe
bien sûr qu'il faut progresser voilà les
lois sur la parité les listes qui ont
été engagés font qu'aujourd'hui j'ai un
engagement de plus en plus important
vous parliez d'expérience et pourquoi on
pourrait pas remonter plus tôt vous
faire en sorte que des gens prennent des
responsabilités plutôt ça vaut en
particulier pour les femmes et ça c'est
un vrai sujet donc tout ça c'est un
processus qui doit se mettre qui
s'enclenche qui est enclenchée qu'ils
vont bossue alors quel constat
faites-vous sur le sur l'évolution
céline pic il ya notamment certains
partis politiques qui préfèrent payer
des pénalités plutôt que d'appliquer la
loi comme ça a été très bien rappelé il
ya des pénalités qui sont impliqués si
les listes ne sont pas paritaire en
particulier aux élections législatives
certains partis préfèrent payer
effectivement des millions d'amande je
pense qu'au contraire il faut aller vers
plus de quotas et plus de parité parce
qu'on voit que sans quota et s'empare
été ça ne bouge pas voir ça régresse
hélas les chiffres sont particulièrement
parlant puisque les maires alors que les
listes sont paritaires dans les mairies
on n'a que 19 % de mer et 11 % au niveau
des intercommunalités et là vraiment les
propositions qui ont été évoqués dans le
reportage sont complètement en ligne
avec les préconisations du hce le haut
conseil à l'égalité qui préconise un
certain nombre de choses en étant
attaché à matignon et il préconise quoi
depuis 2018 il ya un rapport du hce qui
a été publié à ce moment là qui
préconise trois choses fonctionnent et
fonctionne fonctionnement en binôme au
niveau des mairies donc toujours adjoint
et premier adjoint parce qu'on voit
toujours que c'est le maire et ensuite
les adjoints et puis réfléchir aussi à
l'attribution des postes c'est toujours
les femmes à la petite enfance
tandis que les hommes sont aux finances
ou à la construction et puis ensuite
instauré également la parité au niveau
des intercommunalités ça aussi c'est
extrêmement importante on à 11%
deux femmes aux intercommunalités
pourquoi parce qu'on envoie le maire
justement représenter la commune hélas
les
pratiques sexy se remette en place avec
un phénomène d'éviction des femmes et
excusez moi et après je vous rends la
parole promis et ensuite seulement
viendra un moment où il faut travailler
sur
quelque chose de profondément culturel
n'y a pas que les quotas selon les
démocrates
évidemment on profondeur pardon nous
interrompons éric kerrouche parce que ça
c'est aussi un combat le bain
interrompre que les femmes dans un débat
je fait j'essaie toujours de faire
attention à vous écouter les matériaux
employés -
journalistique vous savez eric vous
portez une proposition de loi pour pour
améliorer finalement le système existant
il ya certaines d'aidé
des propositions des idées évoquées à
l'instant par c'est une pique qui sont
dans cette loi notamment imposé que le
premier adjoint soit de sexe différent
du maire ou le premier vice-président de
sexe différent du président pourquoi me
semble important d'aller plus loin
parce que je veux faire une métaphore
économique si on attend que il ya une
espèce de main invisible qui régule la
distribution des hommes et des femmes
aux postes de pouvoir on va attendre
pendant longtemps de la même façon que
le marché ne s'autorégule pas le marché
politique ne s'autorégule pas tout seul
et il lui faut des contraintes il ya un
problème de
diversification des profils en politique
qui est vraiment un des problèmes
majeurs de notre de notre démocratie
ça commence par l'aspect paritaire dont
on parle ce soir mais il ya d'autres
aspects dont on pourrait parler comme la
sous représentation de certaines
catégories sociales et la perspective
c'est de faire en sorte à travers la
proposition que l'on reprenne lente et
propositions du hce et d'autres pour
faire en sorte que les dernières
barrières parce qu'il s'agit des
dernières barrières 8ce tombé et elles
sont en fait assez faciles à faire
tomber si on est un peu volontariste
donc finalement c'est un système de sas
rapproche d'un système d'égouts de
quotas
enfin c'est c'est pas un quota on part
du principe d'abord que
contrairement à ce que disait stéphane
le foll ce n'est pas au dessus de 3500
habitants c'est en dessous de 1000
habitants maintenant et on dit pour qu'
il y ait une représentation paritaire
bien on applique le même scrutin pour
l'ensemble des communes donc partout des
listes paris partout des listes des
listes paritaires et on aura des gens
qui nous diront comme on l'a entendu
dans le passé que c'est pas possible
pour les moins de mille parce que les
femmes dans les communes de moins de
1000 y en aurait moins ça serait
compliqué c'est toujours compliqué et je
suis pas d'accord je suis pas d'accord
avec ça et après il ya un premier pas
dans les intercommunalités c'est de
faire en sorte que au moins à défaut
d'un autre système dont on pourra
reparler au moins la proportion de
femmes dans l'exécutif soit identique à
la proportion de femmes dans le conseil
communautaire dominique estrosi sassone
est-ce qu'il faut voilà
durcir le le système législatif actuel
notamment les les pénalités pour les
partis qui ne respectent pas la parité
ou alors imposé carrément un système de
quotas alors vous l'avez dit au début de
l'émission la parité elle a quand même
progressé on l'a vu sous la pression
sociale croissante mais aussi à travers
un certain nombre de textes législatifs
on a cité le texte de 2000 qui a permis
quand même la parité dans les élections
municipales dans les élections
régionales dans les élections
européennes qui a introduit des fameuses
pénalités financières pour les partis
qui ne présenteraient pas au moins 50 %
de candidats aux élections législatives
il ya eu aussi la loi de mai 2013 qui a
permis aussi une certaine avancée en
particulier à travers le dernier bastion
inébranlable celui des conseils
départementaux et des binômes mais je
pense que pour les propositions qui
évoquait éric kerrouche moi je serais
beaucoup plus pragmatique et beaucoup
plus sur la réserve pourquoi imposer
absolument quand une femme et mère à ce
que son premier adjoint soit un homme ou
à ce que lorsqu'un homme emerse première
adjointe soit une femme vous savez moi
je connais dans des communes des femmes
qui sont maires qui ont choisi une
première adjointe femmes je pense que le
binôme que font un maire et un premier
adjoint c'est une alchimie très
particulière ça nécessite aussi que ces
deux personnes soit véritablement toute
confiance et qu'elle puisse aussi bien
s'entendre parce que le premier adjoint
il n'est pas là uniquement pour
remplacer le maire certes mais aussi en
cas de décès et donc qu'il faut vraiment
qu'ils une alchimie s'est-elle chimie
elle n'est pas forcément déterminé par
le sexe opposé et je vous entends bien
on a suffisamment progressé pour ne pas
dire sinon c'est parce que je veux dire
s'il ya certainement encore des
améliorations mais je pense qu'il faut
pas à tout prix vouloir la parité quels
que soient les cas de figure par contre
sur la proposition que fait éric
kerrouche à travers les exécutifs et le
nombre de vice présidents dans les
exécutifs des intercommunalités qui
s'effectue par miroir du nombre de
membres de l'organe délibérant il ya 45
% de femmes dans l'organe délibérant de
l'intercommunalité et bien qu'il y ait
45%
vice-présidente ne me gêne absolument
pas et je pense que c'est une bonne
solution c'est pragmatique à l'aller pas
une période où de toute façon on n'a pas
la parité dans ces assemblées locales et
où les femmes sont sous représentées
ça permettrait déjà effectivement de
pouvoir apporter une meilleure
représentation des femmes et sur
l'aggravation des des pénalités des
sanctions financières ont coûté je pense
qu'aujourd'hui ces pénalités financières
elles sont suffisamment lourdes pour les
partis politiques à tel point que même
un parti politique comme le mien j'ai
qualifié d'un parti politique pour le
moins assez conservateur a fait de son
chantier prioritaire pour les prochaines
élections législatives 2022 à ce qu'il y
ait la parité intégrale je sais que
christian jacob y est attaché et qu'il
fera en sorte qu'il y ait autant de
candidates femmes que deux candidats
hommes pour les élections législatives à
venir battu aux jo les tarifs de temps
c'est un engagement officiel et on l'a
dit d'accord il a dit je la fis en
commission nationale d'investitures
après commission nationale
d'investigation que je crois que vous
étiez le parti qui avait le plus de
pénalités donc je suis ravi d'apprendre
que planchent aujourd'hui le chantier
ici à une véritablement on tiendra à ce
qu'il y ait la parité intégrale dans des
candidatures aux élections législatives
de 2022 ça nous examinerons avec une
attention ce qui est étonnant c'est qu'à
une pression financière enfin de
pression sociale ou 18 heures y a pas de
pression électorale c'est que c'est très
curieux que cette demande là ne soit pas
relié dans les urnes on sait que les
républicains ont se sont assis sur cette
parité pendant longtemps alors vous
faites de l'effort tant mieux mais j'ai
assez il s'essaie c'était pavot de la
priorité du parti et le parti préféré
géants cet été le seul parti qui étaient
dans ce cas là mais c'était le celui qui
paye et le plus le plus de pénalités
mathieu par efficacité électorale aussi
c'est ce que c'est ce que je veux dire c
est ce qu au moment m 21 ans lyon
pourquoi les républicains à partir de
william 50 % de femmes dans le pays
environnement où un tout un nombre
d'hommes sont pour la parité pourquoi
des gens continuaient de mettre des
bulletins les républicains dans lui
aussi la question de ces la parité était
central c'est ça le racing c'est la
démocratie on est si les gens décident
de voter parce que la personne a bien
rempli son rôle de maire et de
conseiller régional de conseiller
départemental c'est sans prendre en
considération le sexe c'est aussi des
compétences les qualités qui doivent
être mises en avant oui alors que j'ai
ensuite c'est typique ou soit mais ce
qu'il faut pas oublier surtout c'est que
en fait tu sais pas qui a pas de ces
paquets de pression sociale c'est que la
pression sociale ne s'applique pas dans
une circonscription prises
indépendamment on a deux
circonscriptions et en l'espèce on ne
voit pas forcément qu'un parti politique
ne respecte pas de manière globale la
parité les lecteurs ne voit qu'un
élément du débat public les autres
partis nous montre pas du doigt les
républicains
mathieu c'est que les électeurs
sanctionnent pas massivement une liste
qui qui des papas mutation c'est plus
possible
c'est pas que c'est pas forcément c'est
pas forcément une sanction est sauf que
la demande vis-à-vis de la parité est de
plus en plus importante quand vous voyez
en fait l'évolution de l'opinion
publique quand on y met en tout cas sa
mesure dans le temps par rapport à la
parité c'est une vie à une vraie
sensibilité qui se développe ça c'est
vrai dans le temps maintenant là il ya
toujours des résistances mais il ya des
mots ça il faut pas oublier qu'il ya des
bonnes raisons aussi pour expliquer le
fait que les femmes soient moins
présente en politique c'est que on vit
dans une société qui est jean rey et que
en l'espèce les rôles sociaux rempli par
les hommes et les femmes sont toujours
très différents et que d'une certaine
façon
tout se passe comme si l'ensemble des
rôles imputée aux femmes eh bien les
tenait justement à l'écart des fonctions
politiques il faut pas on fonctionne pas
comme ça dans le dans le vide il y a
déjà des réalités sociales qui joue au
détriment des femmes non seulement
politiques mais également je vous le
rappel du point de vue du point de vue
des métiers et des salaires donc ce
n'est pas indifférent c'est la politique
c'est sa incarne cette résistance mais
cette résistance
vis-à-vis des femmes et vis-à-vis du
rôle des femmes c'est une résistance à
sociétal pourquoi d'après vous il faut
des quotas pour briser en partie cette
résistance pour moi il faut des quotas
parce que bon effectivement je pense que
la demande des électeurs est de plus en
plus forte parce que le mouvement
féministe avancer les idées progressent
il faut des quotas parce que les quotas
c'est une obligation de résultat et ça
permet date de développer à l'intérieur
des partis des politique active de
promotion des femmes et de réfléchir
aussi aux freins aux freins qui sont qui
se dressent pour pour l'investissement
des femmes en politique et là moi je
vois deux causes majeures
la première c'est effectivement la
question de de l'engagement comment on
fait pour concilier sa vie
professionnelle et sa vie personnelle
alors qu'on sait qu'aujourd'hui c'est
encore les femmes qui s'occupent des
enfants et que les réunions
76 % il ya quand même plein de familles
où les hommes les pères de famille
s'occupe aussi les enfants à l'art 2 je
pense qu'on vient d'un manque un peu
moderne et qui n'est pas forcément tu
devines c'est
aussi la réalité autour de vous des
changes à des pairs de
creusement qu'il ya des pères de famille
qui s'occupe encore mais regardez les
études même qui ont été faites pendant
le confinement quand les écoles ont
fermé ce sont essentiellement des femmes
qui ont fait la classe à la maison aux
enfants pendant leur confinement donc
oui il ya encore des freins et en
particulier pour les femmes
monoparentales c'est quasiment
impossible puisque l on à 80% la charge
et elles n'ont même pas de relais du
père au quotidien donc oui les choses
avancent dans le bon sens mais beaucoup
trop lentement pour que ça soit pas
considéré aujourd'hui comme un frein ces
75 25 cesser les chiffres de l'insee
très récent et le deuxième frein qui
pour moi est essentiel c'est en faisant
référence à la tribune qui a été qui est
sorti ces derniers jours c'est la
tribune me tout politique oui je pense
que en termes de demande électorale il
va y avoir une demande extrêmement forte
sur le fait qu un certain nombre la
jeune génération qui a investi dans les
mouvements féministes ne veut plus voir
investie des hommes politiques qui sont
condamnés pour viol violences conjugales
agression sexuelle ou harcèlement sexuel
donc ça c'est quelque chose qu'on porte
depuis des années et des années il va
falloir que l'ensemble des parties
entendent cette demande qui est
extrêmement forte des jeunes générations
ça a commencé avec la sphère baupin ça
touche tous les partis sans
fin sans exception ça a commencé avec la
sphère beaupain en 2016 on a aujourd'hui
par exemple huit femmes qui accuse eric
zemmour d'agression sexuelle et je pense
que ça peut être aussi quelque chose qui
soit qu'ils soient déterminants dans les
votes un refus net
moi je pense en particulier aussi aux
manifestations qui a vu qu'ils avaient
eu lieu contre la nomination de darmanin
qui était
sûr qu'ils étaient sous le coup d'une
enquête préliminaire pour viol tandis
qu'il est classé à plusieurs reprises
lors de sa nomination a depuis lors de
sa nomination quand on parle de cette
affaire il faut
200 le jour de sa nomination il y avait
une enquête préliminaire ouverte est
clairement je pense que dans plein de
pays étrangers le fait qu'il soit nommé
ministre il était déjà il était déjà au
gouvernement mais le fait qu'il soit à
l'intérieur
effectivement ça pose des questions et
je pense qu'aujourd'hui ça va être
quelques gens tournent
tout politique dominique estrosi sassone
qu'est ce que vous en penser ce qu'il
faut interdire finalement de vie
politique ce qu'on était alors en ce que
ce débat des vies là on était autour de
cette table pour parler de la parité en
politique peut-on mieux faire je pense
qu'effectivement on dévie pour autant
effectivement le monde politique est un
monde essentiellement masculin mais
aujourd'hui je crois que les mentalités
elle est venue elle change aussi moi en
ma qualité de femme politique qui fait
de la politique tant localement que
nationalement depuis plus de 20 ans je
n'ai pas eu à subir ce type de
harcèlement ou ce type d'actes qui sont
tout à fait répréhensible je ne dis pas
que ça n'existe pas dans le monde
politique et ça existe autant dans le
monde politique dans le monde des médias
que dans le monde économique donc que je
vois pas pourquoi on mettrait un focus
plus important et plus gros sur le monde
politique qui serait un monde qui
pratiqueraient malheureusement plus ce
type de deux d'action et d'actes après
faut-il interdire encore une fois moi je
fais confiance à la démocratie je fais
confiance au peuple et c'est le peuple
qui décide c'est le peuple qui est
appelé à mettre un bulletin dans l'urne
qui connaît parce que le peuple français
d'un peuple éminemment politique qui
s'intéressent à la politique et qui est
à même de pouvoir faire son choix en
toute liberté en toute détermination et
bien évidemment en prenant en compte un
certain nombre de faits d'actualité et
en les intégrant ou pas dans le choix
qu'il aura à faire en mettant un vote à
bulletins dans l'isoloir avec pour
terminer ce chapitre politique et qu'on
fasse un peu le bilan de du quinquennat
d'emmanuel macron mathieu le prix en
république qui avait érigé l'égalité
hommes femmes en grande cause du
quinquennat ce qui donne l'exemple bah
non pas du tout et c'est une constante
depuis son origine le maquereau niçois
d'une aventure essentiellement masculine
je montre une photo
c'étaient les membres de l'équipe de
campagne de madame à court de mai 17
voiliers ya que des hommes alors on les
reconnaît pour certains ce soit benjamin
griveaux richard ferrand je viens de
normandie certains sont toujours là y'a
qu'une seule femme si bête ndiaye qui
était chargé à l'époque de la com et
quand on regarde 80 et demi plus tard
dans l'organigramme de l'elysée mais il
ya beaucoup de visages et de nontron
changé il ya une chose qui n'a pas
changé c'est que ce sont encore une fois
que des hommes qui occupent les postes
clés il ya une chef de cabinet adjointe
quelques conseillère idem pour ce qui
concerne les services de direction de la
présidence de république avec une femme
directrice et elle s'occupe de quoi
donner de la com mais mais quand même le
gouvernement lui les paritaire oui pour
sauver les apparences on avait une femme
numéro trois du gouvernement on rappelle
un barbare accompli mais quand on
regarde là encore une fois les gros
portefeuilles les ministères clés les
affaires étrangères à l'intérieur la
justice mme bercy et mais que des hommes
idem pour la majorité et un dîner très
important qui se passe ce soir à l'hôtel
de lassay richard ferrand reçoit pour
parler de choses sérieuses c'est à dire
la construction de la prochaine maison
commune de la majorité il reçoit qui
françois bayrou edouard philippe c'est à
10,16 guérini que des hommes autour de
la table et puis au parlement il ya
quelques exceptions quand il faut le
dire je pense à la présidente notamment
de la commission des lois à l'assemblée
il ya une brique pilée mai
les femmes elles sont surtout dans des
rôles de porte parole c'est mal qui
préside le groupe il y en a qui sont
présentés mais c'est christophe castaner
les femmes elles sont plutôt envoyé sur
les plateaux pour défendre pour défendre
la politique est ce que c'est un souci
pour faire campagne sur le point de vue
du bilan il ya des choses qu'on avance
et soutient qu'elle macron il n'a pas
plus à rougir que ses prédécesseurs il
avait dirigé ça comme une grande cause à
retourner ya encore plein de choses à
faire mais je pense à notamment la
question de l'île des violences faites
aux femmes elles mêmes plus prise à bras
le corps aujourd'hui par les pouvoirs
publics qu'elle ne l'était il ya cinq
ans mais dans une campagne qui ne manque
pas de figures féminines il faut quand
même le rappeler parce que même si c'est
compliqué pour les femmes de faire la
politique on a quand même l'adversaire
numéro un du président qui est une femme
marine le pen on a une candidate
socialiste anne hidalgo peut-être demain
une candidate les républicains valérie
pécresse bref ça va finir par se voir on
a un vrai problème pour la campagne est
manal macron est entourée que d'hommes
confiait à la rentrée un marcheur banon
semble un peu plus de 50 la
présidentielle et sur ce plan le
problème reste entier alors au delà de
l'entourage du prix en république
c'est une pique est-ce que effectivement
vous donner quand même quelques
satisfecits à l'exécutif au président à
son gouvernement pour avoir fait avancer
la cause des femmes je pense qu'il ya
quand même la pma pour toutes qui était
comme une promesse de campagne et qui a
été finalement réalisé donc on va voir
maintenant si ça se passe bien pour les
fans vont parce que c'est pas forcément
une mesure qui qui prône l'égalité
femmes hommes et pour tout six pourquoi
s'arrêter il ya les illuminations de
l'accès à la non il y avait une
discrimination lie à l'accès à une
technique qui est une fécondation in
vitro est là qui était ouverte aux
couples hétérosexuels mais qui n'était
pas ouverte aux couples homosexuels et
je pense qu on est assez clair osez le
féminisme pour pas de confondre pma et
gpa une fiche c'est une fécondation in
vitro c'est une technique médicale mais
ça n'a strictement rien à voir avec la
gpa donc là les pma et est une une
promesse et cette promesse a été
effectivement tenus après sur les
violences a eu beaucoup de discours
assez fort il faut le dire je me
souviens de le lancement de la grande
cause de le 25 novembre 2017 et puis un
certain nombre de déclarations des
différents ses moyens faire un ministre
est par contre manque de moyens un
manque de moyen sûr sûr sûr
l'application de pour avoir les moyens
de ses ambitions on pense au nom de
téléphone grave grave danger on pense
formation des policiers formation des
magistrats c'est une chose qu'on répète
maintenant depuis quatre ans sur tous
les plateaux et clairement il ya un
blocage au niveau de l'argent on parle
aujourd'hui d'une augmentation de
quelques millions en fait on parle en
millions quand à peu près toutes les
politiques publiques d'envergure on
parlerait en centaines de millions nous
on est là en train d'annoncer un million
supplémentaire pour le sdf donc le
service droit pour l'égalité femmes
hommes donc on parle sur des montants
microscopique ce jeu rappelle que le le
budget d'elisabeth mans rennes
représente 0 001 % du budget on ne va
pas aller très loin encore là dessus et
donc c'est lent et les résultats sont
lents à venir par manque de moyens alors
ça m'offre la transition pour parler
maintenant de l'aspect économique dans
le monde de l'entreprise
il ya aussi beaucoup à faire pour
améliorer les inégalités salariales pour
briser ce fameux plafond de verre est ce
un cliché je pense que non c'est
toujours une réalité dans beaucoup
d'entreprises ouvrir les postes de
direction aux femmes gaspard flamand en
2011 le parlement adopte la loi copé
zimmermann qui impose des quotas de
femmes dans les conseils
d'administration et de surveillance des
entreprises aujourd'hui la ministre
déléguée chargée de l'égalité
hommes-femmes la firme cette loi était
nécessaire
la loi copé zimmermann qui a été votée
en 2010 eh bien nous a fait passer de 9
% de femmes dans les conseils
d'administration à 45 % en seulement dix
ans seulement dix ans des avancées dans
les conseils d'administration mais les
inégalités persistent partout ailleurs
salariale d'abord les hommes gagnent en
moyenne 16 5% de plus que les femmes
autre chiffre marquant une seule
entreprise du cac 40 est dirigé par une
femme pour aller plus loin le parlement
vient d'adopter une nouvelle proposition
de loi qui prévoit pour les entreprises
de plus de 1000 salariés un quota de 40%
de femmes aux postes de direction d'ici
2030 aujourd'hui elles ne sont que 22%
occuper ces postes
et pour aller plus loin sur ce thème des
inégalités d'entreprise j'accueille avec
nous en vidéoconférence hinse a fait la
cynique et porte parole du mouvement
glorieuse vous êtes juriste expert temps
d'égalité salariale et négociation de
rémunération et créatrice de la
plateforme ma juste valeur bonsoir je
reprends ce cet écart de rémunération
entre les hommes et les femmes 16 5% ça
veut dire que symboliquement depuis le 3
novembre à 9h22 les femmes travaillent
gratuitement que comment cet écart est
il calculé
alors c'est un des cas qui est calculé
en fonction du chiffre qui nous est
donnée par eurostat recette nous donne
un chiffre qui essaient de 25% ont
reproduit ce chiffre là sur les jours de
l'année on fait comment un calcul qui
est très simple qui est qu'ils sont la
passe de trois et donc ça nous donne le
la date du 3 novembre
à 9h22 pour l'année à qui est celle que
qui est l'année 2000 un tiers
la tendance malheureusement c'est encore
pire que l'année précédente c'est ça
oui on observe que depuis 2000 16
chiffres ne fait qu'augmenter donc cet
écart salarial ne fait qu'augmenter et
les femmes qui commencer en 2016 qui
était arrêtée de travailler 17 novembre
aujourd'hui en 2021 malheureusement
elles arrêtent de travailler le 3
novembre donc on voit très bien que cet
écart se creuse malheureusement s qui
est aussi un effet crise sanitaire
oui certainement il ya un effet crise
sanitaire et puis aussi un effet crise
économique qu'on ne peut pas dénier à
évidemment c'est quelque chose qui
impacte l'économie et donc comme ses
impacts l'économie les femmes sont aux
profs sont en première ligne et donc
c'est un pacte si le travail des femmes
et le salaire qu'on accorde aux femmes
dominique estrosi sassone reviens vers
vous sur cet aspect économique c'est
gouvernement françois hollande qui avait
instauré des sanctions contre les
entreprises qui ne respectent respecte
pas pardon l'égalité salariale est là et
la parité est ce qu'il faut là aussi on
est un peu sur la même
mécanique ou les mêmes questionnements
que pour la parité en politique est ce
qu'il faut aller plus loin ce qu'il faut
aggraver ses sanctions non cela va dans
le bon sens effectivement ce qui a été
voté mais on voit bien que la
féminisation telle qu'elle a été votée
n'a pas produit les effets de
ruissellement puisqu'aujourd'hui nous
sommes encore confrontés effectivement
en particulier s'il y a plus de femmes
dans les conseils d'administration
on voit qu'il y a moins de femmes en
tout cas qu'il n'y a pas suffisamment de
femmes dans les comités de direction
dans les comics et là c'est un véritable
problème la proposition de loi qui a été
votée à l'unanimité et la semaine
dernière ici au sénat va plutôt dans ce
sens là puisqu'elle a prévu qu'il y ait
au moins 40% de femmes d'ici 2040 pour
intégrer les comités de direction les
comex donc c'est plutôt quelque chose
qui est positif ça prendra encore du
temps on le voit mais je crois que là
c'est véritablement un combat qu'il nous
faut continuer à amener en matière
d'égalité professionnelle hommes/femmes
et surtout de montrer que les femmes ont
les relègue pas où on est mais pas
uniquement sur des emplois parce que
souvent c'est les emplois à temps
partiel ce sont des emplois qui sont des
emplois précaires et qui de fait très
qu'arrive la femme et n'arrive pas à lui
permettre d'accéder à des emplois qui
lui assure une certaine sécurité
matérielle à travers un salaire plus
conséquent et rico show jouissent les
entreprises de plus de 50 salariés sont
concernés par par ces règles sur
l'égalité salariale il faut il faut
baisser le seuil il faut c'est
insuffisant pour vous
c'est compliqué de se prononcer dans
l'absolu parce que après il ya des
difficultés qui sont des difficultés
liées aux entreprises pour autant pour
autant c'est un peu comme la parité en
police et ça s qui s'ils ont également à
6 voix séparent le règlement janot à
grands pas si on ne prend pas des
mesures il ne faut pas attendre que les
choses se régule tout seul ça ne sera
jamais le cas sinon on n'arrivera en
pessimiste que ça c'est la génération
qui est peut-être en train de faire
bouger les choses
d'accord mais dans ce cas là il faut
l'aider parce que en fait il suffit de
il suffit de revenir vingt ans il suffit
de revenir vingt ans en arrière nous
avons connu en ce qui nous concerne
français avec la loi sur la parité en
politique et celles qui ont accompagné
un bond qui est considérable qui n'est
pas comparable à celui qui a été atteint
dans d'autres pays qui a été beaucoup
plus important parce que parce que cette
obligation alors c'est vrai il y avait
déjà notamment dans les pays du nord de
l'europe parce que les partis politiques
et aussi des entreprises s'étaient auto
imposé
dérégulation il y avait des progrès mais
ce que je veux dire par là c'est que
sans la mise en place de ces éléments il
ne faut pas s'attendre à ce que ça se
règle tout seul moi je suis partisan de
la contrainte parce que la liberté a pas
marché c'est aussi simple que ça
c'est une pique sur vous parliez de
ruissellement est ce que vous y croyez à
ça c'est à dire le fait de venir mais
finalement plus de femmes dans les
comités de direction donc à des postes
de direction et pas seulement à la com
mathieu non mais voilà c'est pas
seulement une c'est pas seulement une
voix là pour faire un bon mot
du ruissellement danse madame la
sénatrice excusez moi je dis sénatrice
mais c'est plus fort que moi
je pense que le ruissellement ça ne
marche ni pour les richesses ni pour
l'égalité et je vais aller même au delà
de ça c'est le pardon je vous interromps
bas mais ça veut dire que quand tu
disais femmes sont chefs d'entreprise
vont pas nommé plus de femmes à des
postes de direction ou améliorer la
santé sur l'égalité je pense que
brossette cette loi sur les 40% moi je
trouve qu'elle va dans le bon sens ça va
obliger là aussi les entreprises à
mettre des politique active de promotion
des femmes qui n'arrive pas à émerger
aujourd'hui mais je dirais je vais vous
prendre un exemple très simple c'était
pas parce que vous mettez des femmes
dans le comex de carrefour que vous
améliorer la situation des caissières de
carrefour donc il faut quand même voir
d'où vient ces inégalités salariales et
je pense qu'aujourd'hui on a un focus
extrêmement forts sur les postes de
direction je comprends bien cette
problématique sur le plafond de verre
j'avoue que j'ai quand on regarde les
chiffres il faut voir que maintenant
l'écart à poste égal poste égal n'est
que de 5% alors que
bientôt c'est pourquoi si oui pourquoi
la différence entre les 16 et demi pour
160 m a parlé stegall ça veut dire le
même poste sauf que qu'est ce qui se
passe c'est que les carrières des femmes
et les carrières des hommes ne sont pas
les mêmes l'écart des hommes augmente à
accélère plus vite il ya un décrochage
très fort au moment dé grossesse en fait
à partir du moment où les hommes et les
femmes ont des enfants la carrière
décroche et donc elle prend du retard
par rapport à celle des hommes et
deuxième facteur le choix des métiers
qui est extrêmement structurants et là
je pense que c'est aujourd'hui le levier
essentiel plus que d'aller chercher dans
les comics c'est de montrer et ça il ya
un certain nombre d'études qui sont
extrêmement clair que les métiers
largement féminisée à responsabilités un
travail comparable à travail égal mais
un travail comparable en termes de
responsabilité de compétences sont moins
bien payés c'est à dire je vous prends
un exemple extrêmement simple une
infirmière qui travaille en réanimation
à l'hôpital public aujourd'hui va être
moins payé peut-être qu'un technicien
informatique qui va installer des
ordinateurs dans toujours dans la
fonction publique d'ailleurs sera moins
payés hélas et je vous renvoie aux
travaux de deux sociologues du travail
qui font un boulot formidable qui savent
eux qui s'appelle rachel silvera et
séverine lemière qui préconise elle
plutôt de travailler sur la mixité des
métiers et c'est à dire qui est plus
d'hommes dans les métiers de
l'enseignement du soin et de la santé
parce qu'aujourd'hui lycée des métiers
majoritairement féminin et que ces
métiers là soit aussi jugé d'ailleurs
assez essentiel pour notre société qui
soit revalorisé aujourd'hui les sages
femmes sont en grève c'est pas un hasard
elles sont très très très très mal
rémunérés par rapport aux niveaux de
responsabilités qu'elles ont et par
exemple le métier d'enseignante et ben
en fait il ya 40 ans un enseignant début
de carrière commencée à deux fois le
smic aujourd'hui un enseignant début de
carrière c'est 1,3 fois le smic eh bien
devinez ce qui s'est passé pendant ces
quarante ans ce métier c'est largement
féminisée et comme c'est considéré comme
un salaire encore secondaire et que
c'est un métier féminin il ya une
dévalorisation salarial pendant trente
et un métier sur les mousses se féminise
il se dévalorise parce que c'est ce
qu'on retient notre explication il
s'affaire à signy c'est votre métier
finalement 2 de valoriser les talents
féminins c'est ce que vous faites dans
des négociations de rémunération qu'est
ce que vous proposez pour accélérer
l'évolution qu'on souhaite tous
moi j'ai la profonde conviction qu'il
faut absolument conduire le changement
dans l'ombre de l'entreprise il faut
absolument comme on l'a dit auparavant
malheureusement le marché ne
s'autorégule pas tout seul de la même
manière que le marché financier ou que
n'importe quel marché ne s'autorégule
pas l'âme tout seul le monde du travail
le monde de l'entreprise le marché du
travail ne s'autorégule sera pas tout
seul la difficulté c'est quand on
observe le problème des inégalités
salariales on le prend du prisme depuis
le schisme féminin et on me dit aux
femmes ce qui les culpabilise énormément
vous n'êtes pas suffisamment audacieuse
vous n'êtes pas suffisamment ambitieuse
il faut être un peu plus vocal sur votre
juste valeur un peu plus a certes il est
c mais la réalité c'est qu'il faut aussi
conduire le changement dans de
l'entreprise parce que la deuxième
chambre du problème c'est aussi de la
manière dont les entreprises perçoivent
le travail féminin aujourd'hui encore le
travail des femmes est encore perçu
comme un salaire d'appoint ça c'est une
vérité et les travaux de plusieurs
sociologues ont démontré le travail des
femmes aujourd'hui est considéré comme
un travail secondaire la femme reste
l'accessoire du principal et donc sans
salaire reste un salaire d'appoint et
les entreprises ne sont pas formés et
les ligne managériale et les lignes rh
ne sont pas formés à la juste
reconnaissance de leur talent féminin
aux billets de genre au biais cognitifs
et du coup elles vont mettre en place
des budgets colossaux pour attirer les
femmes dans leur 'pipeline' de
recrutement en revanche elles ne vont
pas construire des environnements
travail qui sont suffisamment
reconnaissance de la spécificité des
carrières féminines pour leur permettre
de développer à tous leurs talents dans
le cadre de l'entreprise d'y rester de
les fidéliser de les retenir et du coup
aujourd'hui et on l'a vu aussi on
parlait des jeunes générations les
jeunes générations quittent en masse et
le monde de l'entreprise
elles sont dans un mouvement de rejet
merci mais non merci elles vont dans le
freelancing elles vont entrepreneuriat
nom dans le monde des start up etc elle
déserte le monde de l'entreprise parce
qu'il n'est pas suffisamment adapté
conçu pour accueillir les spécificités
des carrières féminines ce qui est a
priori normal puisque en réalité quand
on observe les choses au départ le monde
du travail à le monde de 30 de
l'entreprise c'est un monde été créée
par des hommes pour des hommes à
destination des fois des hommes les
femmes n'ont pas été prises en compte
dans l'équation au départ et aujourd'hui
à une vraie conduite du changement qui
doit être mise en place pour pouvoir
vraiment réformer tout ce système là
merci pour cette explication je voudrais
qu'on fasse un focus pour terminer nous
reste quelques minutes sur les métiers
du quai qui qui vont jouer un rôle de
plus important de plus en plus important
dans notre société avec le avec le
vieillissement évidemment de la
population eric et où je l'avais évoqué
rapidement en parlant du du salaire des
infirmières
ça reste un chantier majeur de ceux de
ce quinquennat on le voit en ce moment
il ya des urgences des hôpitaux qui qui
qui ferme la nuit dans plusieurs dans
plusieurs villes qu'est ce que vous
proposez vous est ce qu'il ya une
possibilité de revalorisations massives
des salaires des des soignants et
notamment de ceux qui étaient en
première ligne pendant cette crise
sanitaire alors il ya deux manière
globale et en ce qui concerne le sujet
d'aujourd'hui donc la parité sur le
sable sur la revalorisation des salaires
c'est un des événements majeurs des
thèmes que nous développons actuellement
parce que le problème du pouvoir d'achat
et le point du pouvoir d'achat des
catégories les plus précarisés d'une
part où des classes moyennes c'est un
problème majeur en transe fin c'est
aussi simple que ça mais c'est encore
plus les femmes c'est ça touche à touche
effectivement encore plus les femmes
donc nous proposons une égalité
salariale en cinq ans parce que encore
une fois sans cette obligation on croit
que tu auras pas de réussite c'est
d'autant plus vrai que vous parlez des
hôpitaux mais moi je vous parler d'un
sujet qui est très connu dans les
collectivités territoriales c'est celui
des aides à domicile c'est celui des
auxiliaires de vie où on sait que le
besoin est immense ce sont des ce sont
des travaux enfin extrêmement est
extrêmement dur j'ai dirigé comme
beaucoup un cis et on a du personnel
féminin qui fait un travail considérable
qui fait un travail qui est à 100
physiquement avec une usure physique
parce que le travail toujours et tous
les jours est difficile et que là il
faut des investissements massifs non
seulement en termes de salaire mais on
t'aime en termes d'équipement et que
c'est la condition pour que notre
société continue fonctionné et c'est ça
qu'il faut se dire c'est que
l'investissement de maintenant fait sur
les salaires fait aussi sur les
équipements c'est la condition pour que
nous continuons tous ensemble parce que
le vieillissement de la société il est
là et c'est une réalité et on ne va pas
répondre qu'avec des maisons de retraite
c'est la même chose pour notre système
de santé donc là oui il y à un effort
majeur à faire en la matière dominique
estrosi sassone est ce que c'est est-ce
que c'est pas ça le chantier prioritaire
du prochain quinquennat je dirais que ça
aurait dû être son chantier prioritaire
tout de suite après la crise sanitaire
de ce gouvernement je crois que le ségur
de la santé montre bien combien il a
laissé à sa demande de trous dans la
raquette et que malheureusement un
certain nombre de catégories
socioprofessionnelles plus
particulièrement dans le domaine de la
santé n'ont pas été prises en compte
dans la revalorisation des salaires et
donc à leur juste mesure oui mais quand
on entend par don de vous interrompre
mais le dernier débat des candidats au
congrès ait l'air s'était pas exactement
le thème central 2
de l'émission mais c'était pas le thème
central parce que les médias parce que
sans fond parce que les médias n'en font
pas le thème central quand vous ouvrez
tous les débats
ils ont également parlé du pouvoir
d'achat ils ont parlé d'une prime au
travail pour xavier bertrand par exemple
donc je pense aussi que ça fait partie
bien évidemment de leurs préoccupations
parce qu'on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui on
a beau dire qu'on parle tout le temps
d'immigration et de sécurité mais la
préoccupation première des françaises et
des français c'est celle du pouvoir
d'achat c'est celle de demain comment
est-ce qu'ils vont arriver à vivre de
leur travail pour pouvoir offrir aux
familles et bien tout simplement des
conditions de vie n'est plus décentes
possible mais simplement je voudrais
faire une aparté sur comment est ce
qu'on peut continuer à évoluer que ce
soit dans la parité en politique ou dans
l'égalité professionnelle et salariale
entre les hommes et les femmes je crois
que c'est aussi en portant une politique
familiale ambitieuse et je pense que
malheureusement dans notre pays depuis
un certain nombre d'années cette
politique familiale elles n'existent
plus parce qu'une politique familiale
ambitieuse c'est bien sûr pouvoir faire
en sorte qu'il y ait une démographie
plus importante mais c'est aussi
permettre à des femmes à travers plus de
propositions en nombre de places de
crèche en travers des horaires adaptés
de pouvoir faire en sorte que ces femmes
demain prennent plus de responsabilités
que ce soit dans la sphère politique ou
dans la sphère professionnelle allez un
mot de conclusion alors là je suis assez
d'accord avec vous je pense que de
politiser la question effectivement de
la prise en charge des enfants ça
devrait être aussi un des thèmes de
campagne et d'avoir une politique
familiale qui soit ambitieuse et qu'ils
soient qui promeuvent l'égalité femmes
hommes et a osé féminisme on a pleins
pleins d'idées pour cette future
campagne 2022 et on propose en
particulier
d'axer davantage la politique familiale
envers les familles monoparentales en
particulier les mères qui élèvent seules
des enfants qui sont à 34% sous le seuil
de pauvreté et pour ça on a des idées on
veut indivis individualisé l'impôt sur
le revenu parce que là aussi avec cette
familiarisation d'impôt sur le revenu
qui est unique un en europe en europe ça
n'existe pas ailleurs eh ben on
maintient le salaire d'appoint pour les
femmes et ça il faut cesser cela et
revaloriser les allocations familiales
merci beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce débat voilà c'est la fin
de cette émission je vous donne rendez
vous demain pour un nouveau numéro de
sens public et puis bonjour chez vous
demain matin à royal monsigny sont
invités politiques c'est michaël
delafosse le maire ps de montpellier
bonne soirée